blazers down six trent simons and hood
with anthony and giles now
and carmelo anthony oh got that sweet
stroke going
he's knocked down a couple of mid-range
jumpers reg
trying to get the ball down to giles and
it kind of ricocheted right
back into the hands wasn't in that same
corner he had the game
winner a year ago
oh oh there's no hello anthony again so
there's the bench numbers you can add
three more to that
well there's a reason why this young man
is about ready
well there's a reason why this young man
is about ready i shouldn't say young man
but a man getting ready to move up into
the top 10 of the
all-time scoring lists right now
getting ready to chase hakeem elijah won
two in chain 200 points and change
behind him
carmelo now in his 18th season in the
nba
and he's found a home here with the
blazers he's going to follow oh another
three
lookout look out reggie
carmelo anthony is coming alive
with some respect on his name rebound
okay here comes the heat check right now
and there it goes
three sam cassell furious
on that sideline with the sixers doc
rivers wants the timeout
and carmelo anthony firing on all
cylinders here in the fourth quarter
at the motor center
[Applause]
what a quarter carmelo anthony is
putting together here in the fourth
well 11 points in this quarter that's
the first time he's scored in double
figures since 2018
when he put up 15 versus okc
we talked about old reliable for terry
stotts to have a guy who's going to be a
first ballot hall of famer
coming off your bench this has to go
through mello
mello has to touch the basketball here
here he comes and no trent's going to
pull it short
got another chance though
damian lillard uses a screen
simmons stays with him shot clock down
to three here's carmelo anthony
got to put up a tough one oh keep it
going
carmelo anthony cannot miss right now
there's a 15 in the quarter 9 of 13 for
the game
four of four from downtown 22 points
for mello what a run mb goes back to
work and he's fouled on his way in
i mean think about this one b.a shot
clock running down
desperation shot uses the glass
talking about going in your bag
[Applause]
averaging 12 and a half this year 23
minutes he did make a couple of starts
including a start against the sixers
last thursday in philadelphia and
carmelo anthony
in that game scored 22 points
he and trent were the big stars in that
game last week
portland beat philadelphia with no
damian lillard
no mccullum no nurkic
founding the ball that he trusts i do
like for doc rivers having the size of
ben
simmons on damien lillard
anthony puts it in finds covington gives
it back to anthony
who is fouled blazers in the bonus
and so carmelo anthony to the line to
try to give the blazers the lead as they
call it and draw the contact
clearly a foul so two free throws here
for carmelo anthony
calmly knocks down the first to give the
blazers the lead
the sixers do have a timeout they will
be able to advance the ball here
23 for carmelo anthony 16 points in the
fourth quarter
he started this quarter making his first
six shots
help portland on a 12-4 run makes them
both
time-out doc rivers the sixers will
advance the ball they're down
two potential tie or win
coming up when we come back